foreign
I had hoped to be more rested today I
was intent on catching up on some sleep
last night but that plan was foiled when
our four-year-old came into the room at
about one in the morning because he had
a bad dream and now you know my my wife
is nicer in these situations than I am
and it's not that I'm mean you know I do
take it seriously I try to cons when
there's a bad dream situation and I'm on
the hook for it I try to console
the dream victim especially because kids
really do have terrifying dreams
if you ever listen to them describe
their dreams it's like something out of
a horror movie so like the other day my
it was again my four-year-old had a
different bad dream and uh he told me
about it
and he said that that in his dream he
heard something in the basement and so
he opened the door to the basement there
was a man standing at the bottom of the
steps staring up like silently not
saying anything
and I said well who was the man in the
dream I mean maybe it was uh you know
maybe it was Santa Claus or something
coming to you know try to look at try to
try to see this in a positive light
and he said well I don't know who the
man was Daddy because he didn't have a
face
and I said wow that is yeah that's
terrifying I I am scared now actually
you're spreading the bad dream to me now
I'm infected stop talking about it keep
this to yourself
so I get it with the dreams but um I saw
but I'll try to console the child and
then send them back to their own bed to
sleep or or I'll bring them back to the
bed I'll put them to bed and uh and I'll
say good luck with the faceless guy I
gotta go back to bed but my wife She'll
always let the scared child sleep in our
bed
and that's what she did last night
so our four-year-old ended up in bed
with us
and if you know anything about young
children and how they sleep you know how
this goes like they little kids when
they sleep they're like wind-up toys
that are still wound up but knocked over
on their side so their legs and their
arms are still flailing around so this
kid is thrashing all over the bed all
night he's like pummeling me in the side
of the face
karate chopping me kicking me dropping
elbows
I felt like I was trying to take a nap
in the middle of a mosh pit or something
meanwhile the case he's drooling all
over the pillows and then
morning finally comes
and you as the parent you're like a
zombie Sleepless battered broken
and the kid Bounds at a Bed full of
energy
well rested
[Music]
we're experienced a kind of a
contentious moment in our household
um which I share with you because why
wouldn't I just share it with a bunch of
strangers you know I went into my my
daughter's room uh this this morning
before I left for work to say uh say bye
to Earth I always do and she um she told
me that she had she had lost a tooth the
night before
and she didn't she didn't tell us that
she had lost a tooth because she was she
was running a test she was a smart girl
she's smart and she was running a test
she's like Daddy I lost a tooth I didn't
tell you
she was she was running a test because
she wanted to see like
yeah the Tooth Fairy comes allegedly
but if I don't tell Mommy and Daddy that
I lost a tooth will the Tooth Fairy
still come
because the Tooth Fairy should still
come if the Tooth Fairy exists even if
Mom and Daddy don't know about it Tooth
Fairy should know
and so she told me that not you know I'm
kind of like scrambling and I'm like
well yeah well we we communicate with
the tooth fairy or something I don't
know we have to send her an email I try
to think of an excuse and of course the
whole time I'm thinking in my head like
what why are we doing this this has been
my point all along if I if I could go
back
and redo one thing as a parent go back
to the beginning it would probably be
this I don't think I would do the
the fantasy I don't think I I think I
might not introduce
Tooth Fairy Santa Easter Bunny All That
and the problem is
or maybe you pick one like just do Santa
not the others because the problem is
now they're a package
and the Tooth Fairy is a lot more
frivolous than Santa and it feels not as
important
and also somehow even weirder and
crazier
and harder for kids to believe like
they're going to figure out Tooth Fairy
before they figure out Santa
but now it's a package
so I was talking to my wife about it
she's like oh we can't tell about tooth
fairy because then Santa goes and I want
to get another Christmas out of that
it's uh it's not it's not worth the
trouble I think you're just lying to
your kid's face about it all for what
all for what is what I ask it's
extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here's why expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all expressvpn doesn't slow
down your user experience you can even
stream HD videos with zero buffering
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
that's maybe the best thing about it all
you got to do fire up the app tap one
button and you're connected it's not
just me saying this Business Insider The
Verge many other Tech journals right
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
entire world protect yourself with the
VPN I trust use MyLink expressvpn.com
Walsh YT today and get three months free
on a one-year package that's exp
resvpn.com walshyt
expressvpn.com Walsh YT
[Music]
well you know the Tooth Fairy saga
continues by the way speaking of uh I
just said the truth matters well here's
an example of not telling the truth I
was saying yesterday I my my daughter is
very smart critical thinker and uh which
I'm proud of her for that but um she's
starting to figure the Tooth Fairy thing
out and and yesterday you know I went
into her room before I left in the
morning and she told me that she'd lost
her tooth and um
and she didn't tell us the night before
that she lost it because she wanted she
was running a test to see if the Tooth
Fairy would still come even if she
doesn't tell Mom and Dad and of course
Tooth Fairy didn't come to coincidence
because she didn't tell us and uh and
then so the problem is that my my wife
she she really wants to she she realizes
that it's a house of cards and if you
lose the tooth fairy in the Easter Bunny
then you lose Santa Claus and she really
wants to hang on to Santa Claus for the
kids for one more Christmas it's really
you know she she just wants one more
Christmas out of it which means we got
to keep the Tooth Fairy going and this
is becoming difficult because last night
my daughter I'm not making this up this
is she came up with this on her own
because she's like really trying to
figure this out and so she came up with
a plan
last night where she um
first of all
share the tooth under the pill of course
and she uh put out some food for the
Tooth Fairy I don't know that's not
usually part of the tooth fairy deal the
Tooth Fairy doesn't usually eat
um but so she put out so like a little
bowl of water and I think some peanuts
maybe two thirds peanuts you know why
not Everyone likes peanuts and then she
put out some um some baking soda around
the dish so that she could get the
footprints of the tooth fairy
really tooth fair is probably
probably flying but still and then she
also said yeah she asked if she could
use one of our phones and put up like
put a camera there so she could capture
the Tooth Fairy coming in
and this was this whole plan she
concocted
and my wife told her yes let's do all
that of course I'm saying to my wife
what's your plan here with the camera
part of this how are you going to make
that apparently there's an app for there
is an app for this exact situation where
a little girl is trying to figure out
the Tooth Fairy is real
and um anyway there's an app where you
can have like a Tooth Fairy come in and
show it to the kid
so um we got her she's we fooled her for
another another few months
yay us I'm so proud of us
[Music]
well I hope you had a blessed and happy
Easter uh we had a you know a lot of fun
in my house started with the start of
the day with a 6 A.M
Easter egg hunt outside
um before church we had to get it in
before church and you know it wasn't
going to work to hold the kids off on
the Easter egg hunt until after church
we figured
uh we we do it before so I apologize to
our neighbors for that because we were
outside doing an Easter egg hunt at like
6 a.m fortunately my kids are you know
they're only about as loud as a busload
of coked up spider monkeys so it
probably wasn't that much of a
disturbance I have to say though Easter
egg hunts have become uh they've kind of
gone downhill for me in terms of how fun
they are ever since I got fired from the
job of filling the eggs
before the Easter egg hunts so now I'm
the guy my job is to go hide them
but I don't get to fill them and the
reason I got fired from that job is a
few years ago
you know I had the idea to fill because
my wife you know made the mistake of
given the job to me and she like she she
left me unattended and gave me all the
empty eggs and said yeah I could fill
these and we're going through the Easter
egg hunt and so I filled half of the
eggs with things that no kid
would ever want you know like
olives some of them just had rocks and
grass and stuff and then I also put real
raw eggs in some of the eggs
and I thought it would be hilarious and
it was
um until one of the kids opened one of
the eggs with an egg inside and dropped
it and it splattered all over the place
and got on his shoes and everything and
um and then it was a big scene and my
wife gave me that look that said you
know you're you're banned from doing
this again but I still think I believe
the game
it lent the game some necessary
intensity when the eggs contain both
good and bad surprises that's my feeling
on it
now you you might there are there are
those who theorize
that filling the eggs is a tedious task
and so I did that on purpose so that I
would be banned from it forever in the
future and I would never have to do it
again
that's also a theory I'm not I'm not
going to speculate on whether that's
true or not
[Music]